♪ ♪
GOOD EVENING.
I'M BILL HEMMER AND TONIGHT FOR
BRET BAIER.
A PERSON WHO SAYS THE TRADE WAR
MIGHT NOT BE A BAD THING
CERTAINLY DID NOTHING TO
DISCOURAGE THAT CONCEPT TODAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ROARING OUT SOME
NUMBERS TO JUSTIFY HIS POSITION
IN THE FACE OF A NINE YEAR HIGH
IN THE U.S. TRADE IMBALANCE.
HE ARGUES THE PLAYING FIELD HAS
NOT BEEN CLOSE TO BEING EVEN.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS TALKS TO US ON THE
NORTH LAWN.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> WHERE YOU WERE WHERE JUST
THIS MORNING.
GOOD EVENING, BILL.
FOX'S TELLS --DASH
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL PUT IN
TARIFFS ON FOREIGN METAL, 10%
FOR ALUMINUM, 25% FOR STEEL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROMOTED HIS
PLANS TO EMPLOYEES PUNITIVE
TARIFFS ON ALUMINUM AND STEEL,
TWEETING IN THE LAST 25 YEARS,
AND AMERICA HAS LOST MORE THAN
55,000 FACTORIES.
6 MILLION MANUFACTURING JOBS,
AND ACCUMULATED TRADE DEFICITS
BUT IN THE FACE OF RETALIATION
FROM AMERICA'S CLOSEST TRADING
PARTNERS, PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS AND SAID THERE
COULD BE SOME CARVE OUTS.
>> THERE ARE POTENTIAL
CARVE OUTS FOR MEXICO AND
CANDIDATE BASED ON NATIONAL
SECURITY, AND POSSIBLY OTHER
COUNTRIES, AS WELL.
SPEAK WITH A PRONOUNCEMENT WITH
A SHARP ABOUT-FACE FOR THE
PRESIDENT, WHO ON FRIDAY
TWEETED, "TARIFFS ON STEEL AND
ALUMINUM WILL ONLY COME OFF OF
NEW AND FAIR NAFTA AGREEMENT IS
SIGNED."
IT HAPPENED AS FIRST SON IN LAW
JARED KUSHNER WHAT A DELEGATION
TO MEET WITH MEXICO'S PRESIDENT
TODAY ABOUT NAFTA.
A TRIP HE WAS ABLE TO MAKE
DESPITE HIS DEGRADED SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
THE EUROPEAN UNION HAS
THREATENED TO HIT
PRESIDENT TRUMP POLITICALLY IF
HE IMPOSES TARIFFS.
THE E.U. SAYS IT WILL STRIKE
BACK WITH TARIFFS AGAINST U.S.
GOODS, LIKE BED LINENS, CHEWING
TOBACCO, MOTORCYCLES,
CRANBERRIES, AND ORANGE JUICE,
ALL PRODUCED IN SWING STATES THE
PRESIDENT'S WON.
>> IT WILL HIT THEM WHERE IT
HURTS.
AS HE PREPARED TO TAKE THE HIT?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS PREPARED TO
DIRECT OUR COUNTRY.
THAT IS THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
HE HAS AS PRESIDENT IS TO
PROTECT THE ECONOMIC AND
NATIONAL SECURITY INTERESTS.
>> TARIFFS WERE A BIG REASON TO
HAVE ECONOMIC ADVISOR GARY COHEN
DECIDED TO CALL IT QUITS.
THE STRAW THAT BROKE THE CAMEL'S
BACK, ACCORDING TO AN OFFICIAL.
HE'S A FIERCE OPPONENT OF
TARIFFS.
HE WAS ALSO FACING THE YEAR WERE
THE LEADING ECONOMIC POLICY
WOULD BE REWRITING TRADE DEALS
HE DIDN'T THINK SHOULD BE
SCRAPPED.
THE WHITE HOUSE DOWNPLAYED THE
NOTION THAT TALENTED PEOPLE WERE
FLEEING THE WEST WING.
>> THIS IS AN INTENSE PLACE, AS
IS EVERY WHITE HOUSE, AND IT'S
NOT ABNORMAL THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
PEOPLE COME AND GO, BUT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO DO GREAT WORK FOR
ALSO HELD OVER THE POSSIBILITY
THAT COHN COULD RETURN.
HE COULD BE A TOP CHOICE FOR A
CABINET POSITION WHEN THERE'S A
VACANCY.
>> THEY MAINTAIN A STRONG
RELATIONSHIP AND WILL CONTINUE
THAT RELATIONSHIP AND
CERTAINLY -- GARY WILL BE AN